yeah this is a classic Machiavellian
question rights should be liked or
respected I'll tell you you have to make
hard decisions don't make decisions just
on being liked okay but I think you want
to be likeable you want to be kind and
and thoughtful to people and that's how
you get the most out of them but you
have to make our decision sometimes you
have to terminate people that have
worked for your company for a long time
sometimes you're doing them a favor
because they're in the wrong job so you
have to make those hard calls and I
think in the end if you do that with
humanity and caring in the end you will
be respected and you'll get the results
and so I think these these are very
tough if you lean too heavy to the being
liked you'll avoid conflict and in the
end you won't have anyone introspect
because because you didn't make the hard
call so business is about hard hard
decisions and there's no way you can be
in business and not have to make hard
calls but if you duck them or you start
doing up for your what makes you look
good particularly to the media that's
the sure sign that you're about ready to
go down the drain and you see people get
caught up on a Donald Trump type figure
you know they're all it's all about them
and when that happened sell the stock
you